I want you to recall one particular
memory consistency model that I've discussed with you
before, that is sequential consistency. And in sequential
consistency, the idea is very simple. The idea
is that every process is making some memory
accesses, all of these, let's say, are shared
memory accesses. And from the perspective of the
programmer, the expectation is that, these memory accesses
are happening in the textual order that you see
here and that's the expecation so far as this
programmer is concerned. Similarly, if you see the set
of memory accesses that are happening on a different process
of p2. Once again, the expectation is that the
order in which these memory accesses are happening are
the textual order. Now, the real question is, what
happens to the accesses that are happening on one processor
with respect to the accesses that are happening
on another processor if they are accessing exactly
the same memory location? For instance, P1 is
reading memory location a, P2 is writing to
memory location a. What is the order between this read by P1 and this write by
P2? This is where sequential consitency model says
that the interleaving of memory accesses between multiple processors,
here I'm showing you two, but you can have n number of those processors. Making
accesses to shared memory all in parallel.
When that happens you want to observe the textual
program order for the accesses and the
individual processes but the interleaving of the memory
accesses coming from the different processors is arbitrary.
So in other words, the sequential memory consistency
model builds on the atomicity for individual read-write
operations and says that, individual read-write operations are atomic
on any given processor, and the program order has
to be preserved. And, in order to think about
the in, interleaving of the memory axises that are
happening on different processors. That can be arbitrary and
that should be consistent with the thinking of the
programmer. And I also gave you the analogy of
a card shark to illustrate what is going on with a sequential consistency model.
So the card shark is taking two splits of a card deck and, doing a perfect
merge shuffle of the two splits, and
that's exactly what's going on with sequential consistency.
If you can think of these memory accesses on an individual processor as the card
split but instead of a two-way split you have
an n-way split, and we are doing a merge
way shuffle of all the n-ways. Splits off the
memory accesses to get the sequentially consistent memory model.